you're like we're in like a L'Oreal hair
commercial I guess this whistle pretty
huh hey guys I'm here with Gabby Oh like
I've been on the channel before she has
to be back because gabby is a woman of a
million stories and if you haven't check
out her channel you should if you think
that your roommate situation sucks or
that your love life sucks and I've been
through ages I thought Gabby would be
perfect to help me offer some advice
about roommates
and relationships and just general
real-world issues that you guys have I
think that's a funny theory you're like
hey you're always in really bad
situations and clearly don't handle them
well what if you do have some advice for
everybody else I went on my Facebook
page and asked you guys for your
questions about relationships and
roommates in the real world and here's
what we got how to deal with a messy
roommate you can save yourself a messy
roommate or you the same one I would say
that I'm a little bit of both see it's
always just hard because it's always
gonna call it some type of conflict I
feel like every time you have a roommate
anytime you speak your mind about
something it's going to cause a weird
like well now I'm stepping on eggshells
I think I know people have like had
color-coded dishes we're like your
dishes are red minor green so both
dishes left in the sink you know whose
dishes that is do you ever notice with
roommates when you come home and there's
a sink full of dishes yeah nobody left
their dishes and say hey like whose
dishes are deep every single person will
tell you not me what's weird because
like I'm vegetarian and that's clearly
me there's just gonna be liars oh you're
gonna move in with someone just assume
that there's gonna be a mess around and
that you're gonna clean up after them a
lot and that's how you deal with a messy
room I think like a key to having
roommates is having low expectations yes
and boyfriends know that maybe it may be
true for life just across the board
below and then you'll always be
pleasantly surprised and that's the
answer to all the questions
now what do I do let's see some baby
food or something for some essentials to
bring with you when you move into the
door yeah you went to college I did up
you live in a dorm scenario I did live
in a dorm scenario
I was always an enormous an area that
had a bathroom in the actual my room it
wasn't like a shared bathroom down the
hall so abortion uh did you actually
know I had shared showers in I think it
might have been like 90% of the reason
that I went to the college that I went
that's a real thing I read this thing
like the reason cost of tuition is so
high now and one of them is stuff like
that they stopped making them college
housing and started making them
five-star hotel I love all these
amenities and bathrooms in your use and
that's why college is so expensive what
are some essentials that you would bring
into a dorm but you would obviously need
some sort of like shoes to wear into
your bathroom scenario pizza rolls yeah
we went to berry I would say if when it
comes to down to a dorm room make it
your own I was like super broke through
college so I never got like really
decorate my place or spend a ton of
money on like making it feel like home
cuz you're there for a year you have it
spend a little extra money make it a
little bit homey make it a comfortable
place where you're ready to go back and
besides that make sure you have a
microwave oh yeah microwave can do so
many things you can cook eggs in there
and it smells up the dorm you'll lose
friends eggs is not a roommate friendly
food to make my love of roommates in
Brooklyn and we decided we want to
happen adult dinner party like a dinner
party we're doing this we're inviting
all of our like comedy friends like this
gonna be so fun we're gonna be adults oh
my god we don't know how to make food am
i one roommate Michelle knew how to make
eggs and so we had identified a that was
just like I drop of scrambled eggs Oh
miss and PETA and like just dips
everywhere that sounds like a good time
mom it was great it smelled awful my
friend in college she was always like
watching her way well we all kind of
were trying yeah but we would come home
drunk I was in college everybody would
get pizza and all of these like foods on
the street there was like barbecue and
we would go home and my friends would
make me make them scrambled eggs every
single night we came home that's drunk
I would whip up eggs and we'd cook it
and eat it with ketchup and that was our
tofu friend andy and i lived together he
went out one night and walked back to
her place and was like the first like
week or two we've been in our new place
so it's like really early in the morning
at Bodega for like little convenience
store below or apartments open and we
were starving
wet and for some reason we decided to
get cans of black beans
we're so excited that they had black
beans was like the most edible thing in
this store we just started jumping up
and down hugging each other going bees I
look back to our apartment and you open
them ate them from the can with the fork
that's a real weird thing to eat Grey's
an awful thing to eat because the next
morning not only was i hungover I had
the worst stomach ache and if you've
ever eaten an entire can of black beans
by yourself but it does not digest
that's it well okay the question where's
to meet people everyone seems to be
online or working 24/7 nowadays
including me and I don't know how or
where to find people except online I
have no idea answer that question if you
can answer that for me that'd be so good
I don't know how grown-ups make friends
I think it's about like doing things
like going out of your house to either
like I hate talking to strangers or
getting involved in classes honestly I
met so many people when I first moved to
New York because I did improv classes
dance classes like I've been if you're
not a dancer if you go take like a hip
hop class I was picking up my friend
Matt's class or a couple times and I met
so many friends there to be like hey
this is really cool we should hang out
did you know exactly I don't need
friends but we never hung out no I wrote
an album about my cheating husband but
he's my producer was that a good idea
why is that a real question that is his
scarab oh can we give this boy props
mass was that a good idea or not and I
don't know if he's asking if having his
husband as a producer is a good idea
airing a cheater was a good idea of
writing an album about his cheating
husband who is his producer was a good
idea hi great Tanner uncle I think that
is one of the funniest get backs I've
ever heard of my entire life your ex is
your music producer and you produce an
album about him are you crazy that's
hilarious
hey use your art to s therapy a lot of
times are more Ghaderi P is also a good
therapy how do you tell your friends
you'd rather stay home and stare at the
ceiling then go out to the club like
your friends get upset but you don't
want to go to the club though I don't
know I don't like going to the club
either and a lot of my friends do like
loving but I just show up say like I'm
not really the club person I'm sort of
introverted it's not really my scene
you'll have a worse time if I go with
you yeah I'm not into it and I'm gonna
be really annoying to be a
yeah or maybe go to the pregame and get
out then with the pregame so that's so
many times where my friends are going
out to like karaoke or yeah I love
karaoke you're going to a club or
something I just like go hang out then
beforehand know when they leave I'm like
the Irish goodbye to wait with them as a
club and then as soon as they get into
you're just pleasantly duck out what's
painful that was when nobody knows
you're missing yeah what are the common
signs that she's just not that into you
I think some obvious signs that a girl
isn't into you if she doesn't respond to
your communication so intently I'm
listening like what is I've had a lot of
situations where guys will Excel many
times in a row and they might be twenty
minutes apart they might be an hour
apart they might be two hours apart but
sometimes I'm like showering we're at
the gym right working on a video and I
genuinely didn't look at my phone so
there's a difference between is she not
answering her she like been avoiding my
calls for a long time I also feel like
there's something about if someone's not
asking you questions they're not into
you it's a sign that someone wants to
continue the conversation a lot of times
to get someone talking to you I always
say like ask them questions like start a
conversation with a question ever just
say hi right and so if you're asking a
guy question if you look through my
dating apps right now all my first
messages are high hat like me to the
hi-hi Thank You Gabby for all of your
wonderful advice thank you for trusting
me with that I hope that this made you
guys different people than you were
before the start of this better way I
don't know why you would take a fire
somebody who does not have their life
together at all this is part of your
decor of course you have your life make
sure you guys go check out Gabby's
channel if you haven't already we shot a
video that'll be up over there go
subscribe to Gabby just in general but
she's great people thank you and you
said that I was like yeah hey I wanted
at the most inopportune time I'll see
you guys next time
you know would be amazing huh
what if everybody was just this is a
crazy idea okay like I'm just gonna put
this out in the university what happens
okay what if everybody was just honest
with each other people be too vulnerable
I couldn't do it but right
beautiful.what it like when somebody was
texting you you could just be like hey I
think you're really cool but I'm not
really interested in this or what if
when somebody couldn't tell they could
just say hey I'm just wondering are you
interested like that'd be so amazing
have you ever done that on a day if you
got to a point where you're like so what
are we doing here I will never usually
get too far and dates enough to get to
that point oh yeah because I don't like
people